this is the jonco underground podcast
number 90 sitting here with Echo Charles
EC yes Echo Charlie I got
some I got a little something just a
little just a little something that'll
help out you ever notice there's
something like sometimes you can just
catch a little something it'll help you
out a lot maybe in jiujitsu you learn
like a little a little a little
something it'll help you out oh move
your wrist a little bit over here hey
put your hips a little bit over here
just just a little something but it
helps you out a lot yeah this is one of
those
things uh and it's one of those things
that when you hear it you're going to go
well how is that it's again it's like
Jiu-Jitsu when someone says hey you need
to put your weight over here and you're
like how is that really help and then
you start doing it and you realize it
has a big impact yeah this is one of
kind of one of those things something
will help you out with leadership it'll
help you out with life it'll help you
with interacting with other human
beings here's what it
is uh drum
roll drum roll please there's the drum
roll imagine it in your head and here's
the thing there is more more than one
answer to almost every
question that's it that's one of those
things you just heard it you think oh
well how's that how's that really make
an impact on the world let me tell you
if you can import that and implant that
into your brain it is a very good way to
free your mind and open your mind and
therefore have so much more
opportunity and
flexibility and waste so much less time
it's sort of similar what I was talking
about with Dave Burke when I was saying
that you don't yeah yeah you don't
always have to have an opinion that that
same I think we did a I think we did a
debrief podcast I was talking about you
don't have to have an opinion it's not
required that you have an opinion but
this idea that there's more than one
answer to almost every question it
helped me
out so much in life and I it's something
that I definitely learned in the teams
you know I can TR trace the roots of my
thoughts some of them traced to
Jiu-Jitsu and then they connect to the
teams some started in the teams and they
connect to Jiu-Jitsu some of them
started in the in the tactics of combat
and then they translated to leadership
so I can kind of TR trace the roots this
one definitely definitely I picked up in
the teams and I actually picked it up
from a planning perspective like
planning a mission cuz when you're
planning a mission in the sealed teams
good Lord every single person is a
freaking tactical genius in their own
mind every single person not every
single let me let me rephrase that
here's let me make it legit if you have
a platoon of 20 guys 16 guys 22 guys
whatever your platoon is there's going
to be at least onethird of them that
absolutely 100% think that they know
everything
yeah they're going to say you know one
of them be attack we definitely need
this we need to attack this target from
the north period that's how how
confident they are period they're saying
they will say that like period and then
someone else be negative we need to
attack this target from the south period
so you get two people that are looking
at the same Target and they have
opposing opinions and they both 100%
think that they're right you got one guy
that's saying we need to bring four
vehicles this is a we need to bring four
vehicles someone else like negative we
need six V someone else like no we
should only take three and they all know
this mhm
we should use hilos no no we should
definitely not use hilos definitely not
that's what someone will say someone
I'll just literally saying we should
definitely use hilos for this
op someone will say we need six machine
Gunners we need not hey we consider but
we need someone else will say no we
don't need we need we only need
four other guys need to be more mobile
that's what they're saying mhm stating a
fact what they think is a fact so
everyone has the answer to every
question and what I realized 99% of what
they were talking about 99% of what they
were talking about didn't matter it
actually didn't matter it didn't
matter cuz you know what you're going to
get to that Target and it's not going to
look the way it looked on the map and
you decided yeah we're definitely hit
from the north you're going to get there
and there's going to be a big obstacle
there and you can't hit it from the
north or you're going to bring a certain
number of vehicles and you're not going
to have enough people to Target or
you're going to have too many it's like
it's all it's all subject to what
actually unfolds in the world so early
on I realized you know what there's no
100% right answer so you got people that
are freaking out about the dumbest thing
and they think they've got the 100%
right answer and they they actually also
think that every other answer every
other possibility every other variable
is straight up
wrong wrong that's what they're
thinking what the the attitude I got
into the attitude I adopted was yeah
that'll probably
work hey that that'll probably work you
know like it's a totally foreign
attitude in the SEAL Teams to be like
that'll probably work you know because
everybody wants to be
perfect you know that that probably work
no one wants to hear that in fact it
kind of sounds weird to say right like
we're going to go hit this target I
recommend we hit this target from the
north it'll probably work no one wants
to hear probably so we overemphasize our
confidence to make people believe that
we know what's
up but I got used to that I got used to
that you know hey it'll probably work
cuz 99% of the time that idea probably
would work and it would work from the
north but it would also work from the
south it would work from the West it
would work from the East doesn't really
matter sure could there be some giant
channelized area if you come in from the
East and everyone's gonna be forced into
a small little spot where you could get
ambushed and that's not a good idea yes
that's definitely possible but you all
the other directions look pretty Dam
good all probably
work and it and you know what it might
not be the most perfect it might not be
the most efficient but it'll work and
that's
fine it's fine especially from a
leadership pos position because if you
use their idea you're building up that
relationship and you're saving time
instead of arguing and trying to
convince someone you're just like yeah
you're ideal primor let's use
it but here's the thing this isn't just
about the teams that's where I learned
it but this if you can kind of do this
with everything with ju with ju almost
everything almost everything has more
than one answer even these
crazy whatever political Road you want
to go down there's always there's more
than one answer like anybody thinks they
can take some super
complex uh political decision and think
that they have the 100% right answer
they're just wrong you don't have the
100% right answer you might have a good
answer you'll have Pro you know what you
have you'll have one that will probably
work yeah you probably work you know it
probably not going to work that great
you know because nothing in the
government is going to work
great but you make something it's
probably going to work okay well let's
go with it let's try it
but let's not put all of our chips on
that on that one bet that's not a good
idea so if you as a human being can
remember that there's more than one
answer to almost every question it's
going to make your life a lot easier
you're going to realize there's more
than one way to build a
business there's more than one way to
save money there's more than one way to
reduce expenses there's more than one
day way to cook a steak you ever heard
these people they tell you there's one
way to cook a steak but I had a lot of
different steaks in my day yep and look
there's some that are better but there's
also some that are equally as good and
they're different yeah and I'm not
turning them away not I'm not saying hey
I don't want to eat that steak take that
ribe eye away from me I'm not saying
that I've never said that
yeah there's more than one way to change
the oil of your car there's more than
one way oh you'll like these cut weight
more than one way to cut weight there's
more than one way to gain strength
actually there's more than one way to
communicate to other human beings
there's more than way one way to learn
there's more than one way to grow
anything you know they try to do this in
the SEAL Teams with um combatives yeah
combatives it was like we need to use
this
system and the whole time that I was
advocating for a an evolution in our
combatives program what I was saying
everyone wanted me to pin down a system
the system I wanted to use was having an
open mind that's the system I wanted to
use like hey let's let's just continue
to evolve and figure out what works and
make adjustments as we go because
there's not just one answer there's not
a
[Music]
system so keep that in mind there's more
than one answer and if you can do that
if you can
actually
recognize that there's more than one
solution to problems it is an
outstanding way for you to free your
mind it'll make everything better that's
what I got for today Ecko Charles so
it's like and this is going to come as
no surprise to you but I did figure out
early on in this speech that yeah it's
going to come down to like is that a
speech monologue if you monologue Ted
Talk
solo so and it comes on to your ego
right where it's like oh yeah this is my
way cuz you bring up like steak like
cooking steaks that's a big one right
where um and I have a I have a younger
brother who's a barbecue guy like he's
really good at it actually and but I'll
I'll tell you straight up I've witnessed
it been a part of his barbecue scenarios
for many years and he's very good at G
yeah GTG by far um but he's like no TR
trigger grills like anti I'm anti-
trigger you know cuz it like goes
against the art I guess I don't know he
didn't explain why but so I remember
thinking like oh because that's his
personal approach to barbecuing you know
and and Trager might have been a I don't
know like it maybe takes away it's like
you know when you go digital versus film
kind of a thing on the cameras you know
the digital crap what people are
offended the digital no matter it
capabilities you know who cares about
the capabilities it's just wrong it's
wrong this is the way my way the film
that's the right way um so yeah it can
kind of limit you you know if you if you
stay dogmatic to your one way totally or
whatever and then so if you were to be
able to let go of it I could think of
like literally 10 scenarios right off
the top of my head that I would be doing
or one would be doing a lot better in
life if you were to just let it go yeah
the idea of what you just said of
adapting being able to
adapt let's face it look I have a
trigger boy I'm down with the triager
and I'm not even down cuz I use the
trigger you know who's that uses the
trigger everyone else in my family cuz
I'm not
cooking you know what I mean like hey
I'm sorry hey I get it your brother's
into barbecuing it's a thing right yeah
Leif Babin yes sir it's like you know
he's going to barbecue whatever like
it's Wednesday he's planning to barbecue
on on Saturday that's a he's doing
Mission planning you know what I mean
going to the store prepping me like I'm
not doing any of that that's real I'm
getting a can of chicken opening it up
putting mayonnaise in there I'm eating
it that's what I'm doing you were just
telling that takes a minute and 42
seconds and I'm eating and I'm good I'm
not going to I don't have the patience
for it understand I have the time for it
but like my wife she cooks on that
triager
yeah
right my son Cooks on the trigger good
to go BR it's real doing the straight up
uh the straight up reverse searing
straight up reverse sear it's no joke
dude yeah so anyways if you have a
closed mind and you think well there's
that's not my way is the only way yeah
yada yeah so it's in a way and I like
the film versus digital and the even the
trigger versus you know wood I I don't
even I don't know that much about
barbecue but Trager is wood it's wood
pellets yeah I think it's like there's
it does kind of what what do you call it
kind of bypasses a certain part of the
process of barbecuing I think maybe the
traditional part I I don't know either
burning your freaking meat that's what
bypasses but it's almost like hey if you
were to took take a bird's IV you just
be like hey let's say you're good at
barbecuing super good at barbecuing
super good but you're anti-er you know
how how much capability you would have
if you could do both if you were both I
was into trigger I'm into wood fire I'm
into charcoal I don't know all the
different F the TR yeah you know even
stove top I do it all cuz hey they all
work and I'm good and think of how much
you learn you're going to get better at
your
main uh uh technique yeah if that's like
oh I I don't like
using that is a little excerpt of what
we are doing on the Joo underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen go to Jo underground.com
And subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us strengthen this
Legion of Troopers that are in the game
with us so thank you it's Joo
underground.com it cost
$818 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assist atjo underground.com and
we'll get you taken care of until then
we will see you
mobilized
Underground